ROIP
>> I'm Rachel BOOEN, Been.
>> We just announced a
comprehensive
update to Material design.
Hopefully you enjoyed that.  We
will talk about material
theming, which is a new approach
to customizing
apps, powered by open-source
components, new tools, and new
design guidance.
We've created all of this work
focused around two major goals.
First, we wanted to do more to
improve the design tore
developer workflow.  That was a
big focus for us in this work.
We want to make it faster and
easier to build custom and
improved experiences.
And second, we wanted to make
Material more adaptable and
flexible so
that new products can brand can
come to Material and take the
benefits from it.  This will be
focused on how you move
from customizing and design to
realizing that customization in
code.  We will cover both halves
of that.
We launched in 2014 as a way of
creating a unified
cross-platform set of
experiences.  It was designed
not just for Google and not just
for Android, but for everyone.
And we wanted it to be able to
span
mobile, desktop, and other
devices along the way.  And
since then, we've seen an
incredible amount of beautiful
and
usable products produced by you.
Built on the foundations of
Material design.
We have winners of previous
years
Material design awards from
"New York Times" to air BnB and
more succeeded because they were
able to bring their brand to
bear, the strength
of their identity into the
forefront of the experience
without compromising
predictability or introducing
confusion for the user.
With Material theming, you can
create a custom theme of
Material, which
is personalized for you product,
expressing its brand through
color, type, and shape.  For
today's talk, we're going walk
through three steps involved in
useing Material theming.
Rachel will tell you about using
design itself
.  Then Rachel and I will walk
you through a set of different
examples of how you create
different themes for different
apps and brands, and Josh is
going to show us how to realize
all of this in code.
That's the plan for today
.
>> R
Defining surface relationships,
the user understands how to use
your
products
.  Fundamental guidelines such
as
layout, motion, and so on
provide the scaffolding to
create the beautiful and
functional products.  And
components are still the
building blocks of great product
experiences.  We've expanded
componentry over the years, as
many of you might have noticed,
introducing things like the
bottom Nav, and the bottom app
art which you probably saw on
stage and you will see in our
presentation.
We've strengthened the
usability.  For example, last
year we released a new text
field component to increase
usability and discoverability
within
this component
.  Starting today, there will be
a theming section which will
showcase how
components can be easily
customized from the baseline
Material theme.
Then you can use the Material
theme
editor to execute this cascades
customizations throughout your
brand components.
Let's talk ABTS about a few of
these customizations that make
your product come alive.  We
launched a beautiful color
palate and a way to think about
how to apply color to your UI.
What if your brand color was not
in
this palate? A new tool in the
guidelines creates
beautiful Material
palates and gives you tools to
add to your palates.  You can
generate palates in the Material
theme editor, but the theme
editor takes this a step
further, applying across your
symbol library.  It helps check
for accessibility.
Using the full palate to provide
alternative colors that meet
accessibility standards.
So let's talk about type.
We introduced the same
capabilities with typography.
In 2014, we released a
comprehensive scale that mapped
to components.  Today we can
create beautiful type
scales for any type face, not
just Roboto.
These are often configured to
work across Material components.
And for shape, today with the
launch of the theme editor, we
are introducing
the ability to customize shape
so that rounder corners or
detail on some of your surfaces
immediately apply across all
surfaces within your design.
And lastly, Akon
iconography, resulting in a
collection of over 1,000 icons.
Today we're announcing four
additional sets of icon,
expanding the visual range of
the original set.
Available on Material.
io, they allow for more visual
expression in the smallest
details of
your experience
.
-- Android, web, and Flutter.
So let's go deeper.  We want to
show you how efficient
customization can actually be
.  Making sure our system works
for a wide variety of
experiencing and brands.  You
will see these used throughout
our updated guidelines.  Today
we will talk about a travel app
here shown on desktop.
Reply, an e-mail app, and a
retail app shown on tablet.
This visual shows how they would
originally appear pre-Material
theming.  You can see how
similar the structure
and visual design of these
screens are
.
I will start with an app
called
crane, which is a travel app
.  It is editorial, using
beautiful image lists to
showcase and browse content.
Crane's brand is refined but not
unfriendly.  The brand needs to
give the user confidence that
they can book travel and accept
payment, but also lively enough
for vacation planning to still
feel exciting.  A lot of that
personality starts with color
decisions.
Crane's primary color is purple,
and uses variants of this color
to distinguish and create
contrast, and the
secondary color is bright red,
used for important information
and selection within the
experience.
The purple is the main color of
the buttons, and second color is
used for selection controls and
typographic elements and places.
But if we use red for type and
selection controls, what about
error states?
Very observant if you noticed
that
.  Speaking of text fields,
crane uses two styles that
you'll see here.  This is the
lighter weight outlined text
field used for longer scrolling
forms
.  This is used for search and
user preferences.  They have a
custom shape with rounded
corners and use the brand
colors, the
iconography and typography.  And
we mentioned crane's emphasis on
editorial content.  They use a
styled grid list where photos
maintain their aspect ratio so
they show as much content as
possible.  The image list has
been -- with each item, custom
padding has been added above and
below the item.  Okay.  Josh,
your designer has given you a
beautiful design.
Can you make it?
>> JOSH ESTELLE: As a
developer, I love a good
challenge, and I love making
beautiful designs come to life
and really putting them in the
hands of our users.
Our engineering team has been
hard at work creating building
blocks for great
design, complete with
flexibility
necessary
.  We have done this through
open source
libraries, available for
Android, iOS, and Flutter.
I will walk you through how we
get started building this with
MDC web.
I can quickly drop in the basic
structure of an app
.  This is what it looks like
before I begin customizing
anything.  This will give you
users a great experience right
out of the box.  But today we're
talking about customizing
materials for your brand's
specific needs.  I will show you
how easy that is.
First, color.
Rachel told you about our new
color system
.  From the tools, you can
easily pull
in the colors necessary by
defining these variables.  These
variables are used throughout
the MDC components and can be
used
anywhere within your app to give
understanding to how color is
applied.  While all MDC
components will automatically
pick up and adapt those colors
we just defined, you can
customize things when necessary
.  A tabs default to colors
expected.
On this app, they are part of
the top app bar which uses the
primary color as your
background.  The default black
that tabs use is too dark to put
on top of that primary color.
So here we show how we -- and
this is what that looks like.
Reply's promise to users is not
especially complex.  It's an
e-mail app.  It wants to be
clearly organized.
It wants to have legible
typography and straightforward
navigation.  But we have
customization opportunities
within that.
Reply's brand is focused on
friendliness.
It's come PEpetence and maybe a
hint of quirkiness.
On mobile, reply uses the bottom
app bar.
You see the floating action
button,
and it has been nested into the
app
itself with that nice little
cut.  Doing that increases its
prominence.
A key action as our Fabs often
are, and this makes it an
obvious target.  It's a little
less obvious, less
prominent, uses the reply logo
to access a traditional
navigation panel.  You might
notice something interesting
going on with the icons
themselves.  They're using one
of the new sets that Rachel
described earlier, in this case,
the two-tone version.
Now, these icons are still
immediately recognizable.  We
haven't changed the way that we
draw the similarable symbol.  We
have stylized it.  The entry
chips in the middle of the
screen here, those use custom
color and typography, and we've
also adjusted some of the
lay-out elements.
Inside of the avatar been inset,
we customize it to be a bit
larger, completing the rounded
shape and giving you the
slightly better chance of
actually being able to tell who
that is
.
It needs to cover a lot of
different use cases or tasks
related to this very text heavy
application.
So we've done customization here
as well.
We've taken the default Roboto
and replaced it with Work Sans.
We've updated the weights using
the guidance out of the Material
theme editor.  With the bold
headlines and less emphasized
captions and body text, we
increased the scanability of the
content.  And you can see that
really clearly in a view like
the messaging list here.
There's a clean visual hierarchy
and the user's eye knows how to
jump down the page to catch the
different titles that are there.
On the cards themselves, we
customized them to use sharp
corners, and we decreased the
padding between the cards so
there's more space to get
content in.
Even though there's no
indication of elevation on the
cards, you can still see a clear
separation between them.  You're
getting a little bit of that
background color peeking through
between the cards, cueing that
these are different surfaces,
and that the user
can reasonably expect to perform
swipe
gestures on them to star or
delete one of the messages.
That's a lot of customization.
Can Josh build it?
>> JOSH ESTELLE: So I already
showed you MDC web.  I will
bring you through MDC Android.
No matter what platform you're
building for, you have a
consistent set of components
available, the same patterns,
features, themability, but very
much in line with the platform
specific paradigms that your
users are going to expect.  So
here on Android, we have the
same material theming for color.
We define our theme inheriting
for the
Material components theme and
define our brand colors.  This
defines the colors that will
flow
through the app, styling both
the MDC components and UI
elements.  Now for reply, we
really need to exercise our
ability to customize
typography and use the Material
type
scales
.  Work Sans is the type face
for reply, and this is all you
need to have that font
downloaded on the fly whenever
necessary for your app.  Once we
have the font, we have to apply
our material type scales that
our tooling will help you
determine.
Here we redefine the headline
one text
appearance to use Work Sans with
a light text style.
We can apply and link up to to
our theme so that all update
across your app.
So with those changes to our
theme,
we see replies, colors, and
typography
permeate through the components
and views of the app.  Now let's
look at specific components.
First, chips.
Chips can be versatile, and
complicated to implement well
and in a consistent well.  So
we've done that for you.
Pull in the MDC Android chips
like this, very simple.  Drop it
in your layout.  Getting all the
nuanced behavior of a chip just
right, and completely pulling in
your theme colors and type
definitions.
And of course, the new bottom
app bar with that special place
for the floating
action button this is one of the
nice patterns that might seem
like it would take forever to
figure out how to build.  It did
take a while, but we've got that
for you, too.  Here is the
bottom bar and floating action
bar, automatically pulling in
your theme colors and type.
We're using our new Material
two-tone icons.
They are available on Material.
I/O
.io
.
>> RICHARD FULCHER: So now we
will
move on to the next app.
So, because of this, a lot of
the emphasis is on imagery.
The tonal color pal
palate has minimal interest.
Think about what a user coming
to this experience is looking
for.  They want to engage with
the content.  They want to be
excited by the different wares
you have up for sale and keep
their focus there.  But you also
need to be able to convert them.
They need to be able to find
that add to cart button and hit
it when it's time to make the
purchase.
You're balancing content
browsing and specific execution.
With that in mind, shrine's
brand
recedes a little and content and
key actions go forward.
Where
shrine shines is in the way it
uses shapes.
We use sharp cuts on surfaces
like buttons and larger sheets
of material.  And those are all
tied back to that diamond logo,
the product logo of shrine
itself.
Those aren't just aesthetic
choices.
When we do the surface cuts on
the corner, we are communicating
how the surfaces are arranged in
Z space and how the user might
be able to interact with them.
So from front to back, you have
the backdrop back layer where we
have a custom navigation menu
for shrine.  In the middle, we
have the backdrop front layer,
which is where the bulk of the
content the user is actually
going to engage with is going to
reside with.  And then the
shopping cart sheet which is
tucked almost entirely off
screen,
and it is out of the view when
it's not needed.
On tablet and desktop, shrine's
primary navigation is through
tabs.
On keeping with the emphasis on
storytelling through shape,
we're using a highlight
indicator that takes a custom
shape and draws it behind the
active label.  Last time, Josh,
once more?
>> JOSH ESTELLE: Okay.
So this time, let's talk about
iOS.  Again, I'm going to show
you how colors are defined very
simply and easily get applied
throughout all of our
components.  For each platform
you define these colors and
trust that we've applied them in
the appropriate places across
all the
UI elements.
This is one of the areas that
I'm really excited about.
It's tricky to implement these
things,
but we aim at making it as
simple as theming any other
aspect of your design.  Here we
used this cut on the corners of
the buttons and on the top left
corner of the larger surface.
On iOS, you can use our shape
generators and cornerate them to
stylize.
Here you see a bigger 32 pixel
cut, but only applied to the
top-left corner of the card this
takes care of a ton of
complexity and making touch
targets
behave correctly, ripples and
shadows appear in the right
place.  With all of this, you
get an easy, interesting way to
apply custom shapes across
everything you do.
Now shape is still a work in
progress.
I showed it to you here applied
to buttons and cards, but it
will be coming to many more of
our components soon.  With that,
hopefully I have gotten you
excited about Material
components, the benefits, and
the ease with which they
offer the customizations
.
>> RICHARD FULCHER: So if we
revisit
these apps, they feel much more
distinct and like themselves,
which is the goal.  We haven't
changed any essential
structuring of the information.
It's all the same content and
navigation, but we've added a
lot more of the brand's
character in through this work.
And, everything that you see is
still entirely consistent with
the fundamental principles of
material design.  We are not
introducing anything that's
going to be unfamiliar to the
user.  They're still going to be
able to work through these
systems.  Crane is still making
use of bold
color, but it's flexible enough
to be able to tell a selection
state from an error state, as we
saw.  Reply is using a different
style of icons, but they are
still recognizable and familiar
to the user.
And shrine is still giving
separated surfaces so they know
where they can touch and how the
surfaces might respond.  That's
the power of Material theming
and the goal we have been
chasing.  Starting from the
foundation of Material itself
that solid Material foundation
of good design, and customizing
the experience through key
attributes which have
wide-ranging impacts throughout
the experience.
Today we've just kind of
concentrated on three of our
example apps.
There are actually four more at
material.
oi so you can see other
customization options to get a
sense of the full capability.
While you're there, you can see
how
other real brands are using
Material theming.
So you can read about how we
applied
the Google Material theme to
products like Gmail, news, pay,
and home.
And, over the last year, we've
partnered with the stellar
design teams
from genius, Lyft, and Zappos to
help bring Material design into
their
products YOCHLs.  You can read
about these partners and
Material on Material.io as well.
This is just the start.  We
will be adding new components,
options, guidance, and examples
on a regular basis.  We're very
excited to see what you do with
Material design.  Thank you for
joining us today.
[ Applause ]
If you would like to learn a
little bit more, we have
sessions coming up, about four
or five different sessions that
cover different aspects of
Material
throughout the remaining couple
of days
of I/O.  There's a session later
today on stage 4 that goes
deeper into using Material to
design and build across
platforms.  It's a good session,
and you will probably enjoy it
as well.
And we also have just outside
this stage is the design and
accessibility dome.
We will be there throughout all
of I/O.  Come.  I'm sure you'll
have questions.  We are happy to
answer them there at the dome.
Meet designers from the Material
team.
You can see demos of Material
gallery, Material theme editor.
You can also get a designer
review for your app.
You can get a 15-minute slot to
talk through what questions you
might have about material or
design in general.  And we also
are going to be doing a
series of short ten-ish men knit
talks, small form on different
topics TLOUGTD
the next couples throughout the
next couple of days of I/O.  So
thank you and have a good rest
of I/O.
RAW FILE
Google I/O
Build with Google Pay
May 8, 2018
3:00 PM PDT
Stage 6
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
800-825-5234
www.captionfirst.com
***
This text is being provided in a
realtime format.  Communication
Access Realtime translation
(CART) or captioning are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
>> Welcome. Please fill in
the seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm GER rah Gerardo, with me is
my
partner in crime, Varouj.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Who's
excited
about Google Pay today?
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: Great.
So earlier this year, we unified
all of the ways that you can pay
with Google into a single brand
called Google Pay.
With Google Pay, you can pay
online and at millions of places
all around the
world with the payment
information that you saved in
your Google account.
Today, we're going to be talking
about
the great ways in which we're
making it
easier, faster, and more
rewarding for
your customers to check out
online and
in stores.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: We want
to make payments easy for
everyone everywhere.
See, Google Pay is not just an
app.  Google Pay makes payments
a foundational and integral part
of a Google user's account.
So, if a Google user is logged
into any Google service, they
can experience amazing payment
experiences that Google Pay
provides.
The other advantage to tying
everything to one account is
that
payment methods and transactions
can all
be managed in a central location
.  Now we all know that mobile
is the
fastest growing e commerce
surface, but
your customers are transacting
on all surfaces.  So we want to
make sure that with
Google Pay that Google users can
pay as
easily in stores with a tap as
they can online at your sites
and apps, as well
as on Google, on Chrome, on
YouTube
, Google Play and even Google
Assistant.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: So what's in
it for all of you developers out
here in the crowd? Currently,
there are hundreds of
millions of payment methods
saved to
Google Accounts when users
transact on Play or when they
save their cards in Chrome.
We know from operating
Google
Play that these users that have
saved payment methods to their
account are
much more likely to complete a
transaction than when they
haven't.
And we call these users
ready-to-pay users.
Via our APIs, we're going to
enable
these ready-to-pay users to also
check out quickly and easily in
your own apps
and websites, which means that
you're
going to see increased
conversion rates, faster
monetization, and you'll be able
to provide your customers with
the same
easy, quick check-out experience
that we
provide on Play.
Speaking of payment methods,
let me turn to the Google Pay
app.
So in an upcoming update of the
Google Pay app, we're going to
allow you to manage all the
payment methods in your Google
account, not just the payment
methods that you use to pay in
store.  And even better, we're
going to
provide you with a holistic view
of all
your transactions, whether they
be on Google Apps and services
such as Play
and YouTube, whether they be
with
third-party merchants such as
Walgreen's and Uber, or whether
they're transactions that you've
made to friends and families via
our peer-to-peer service.  And
of course the app is available
on Android, but I'm really
excited to tell you all that
we're bringing this
capability to iOS and the web.
Whoo!
[ Applause ]
So let's dig a little deeper
into the Google Pay app.
If you open the app, you come to
a home tab, and hopefully many
of you have seen this.  And this
tab is personalized for you
based on the credit and debit
cards in your Google account,
based on the loyalty programs
that you have saved to Google
Pay, based on the offers you
have saved to Google Pay, and
even based on the stores that
are nearby you.  You can see
examples of the many types of
cards that you might find in the
home feed of the Google Pay app.
Now what's really exciting is
that some of these cards are
actionable.  So for example,
this card that you see
here allows you to sign up for
balanced rewards, or if you
already belong, its allows you
to link your balanced rewards
account to your Google account.
And this card is geoaware.
It only shows up when you're at
wall
green's
Walgreen's.  So merchants out
there and providers of loyalty
programs and offers programs
that wish to take advantage of
these features should join the
ranks of the hundreds of
partners that have
implemented the Google Pay APIs
for loyalty.  And to learn more,
I encourage you to go to G.
co/pay/business.
Now, we're also working with
ticketing provider
s so that our users can easily
and quickly save event tickets
and boarding passes to their
Google account, and then be able
to access them right in the
Google Pay app.
I'm excited to announce some of
our early access partners, some
of which I see out here in the
crowd such as
Singapore Airlines, Southwest,
EventBrite, and Fortress GB, who
provides ticketing
infrastructure for soccer
matches in the UK and beyond.
I will now turn it to Varouj.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: So Google
Pay covers most of what is in
your wallet, but transit is a
massive use case.  Google Pay
already supports transit
and has for a while at transit
agencies
that accept contactless credit
or debit cards.
We see transactions in London,
Chicago, Kiev, portland, and
coming soon in Vancouver.
But if we only support
contactless
credit and debit cards for
transit, we will leave a large
portion of our Google
users that use TRAtraditional
cards underserved.
So we have been partnering with
providers like NXP
and others to natively accept
these payments within the app.
You may have heard that we
launched in las Vegas as well as
in portland.  And today we would
like to announce
that coming soon we will have
support in West Midlands in the
UK.  So very, very exciting.
ITSO and others to natively
accept these payments within the
app.  You may have heard that we
launched in las Vegas as well as
in portland.  And today we would
like to announce that coming
soon we will have support in
West Midlands in the UK.  So
very, very exciting.
Google Pay is already
available to hundreds of users
in 18 markets.
Just recently, Google Pay passed
million downloads in the Google
Play store.
But we're not stopping there.
Very soon, we will be launching
many
of the core features and the
Google Pay app globally.  That
means that billions of users
worldwide will be able to
leverage the amazing payment
experiences that Google Pay
provides.
So we're very, very excited
about this.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: It is super
exciting.
And users in the UK and the US
have one more thing to be
excited about.
We are bringing peer-to-peer
payment right into the Google
app.  That means you will be
able to send
and request money directly from
the app on the send tab.  But
more exciting than that is you
will be able to easily split for
those tickets -- that purchase
for tickets to
the soccer game or the drinks at
the pub, easily, right from the
Google Pay app.  So if you pull
up the transaction details after
paying for drinks at the pub,
right from there, you will be
able to split the expense with
your friends.  Super exciting.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Awesome.
And guess what?
For many of these payment
experiences, you don't even need
to have the Google Pay app
installed.
Our P2P experience is embedded
in
Gmail, contacts, assistant,
Android
messages and Apple iMessages
.  Last year we demonstrated how
users can directly add credit or
debit cards from their bank's
mobile apps to Google Pay.  But
now you can sign up for a new
credit or debit card in the
mobile banking app, add that
privilege to Google Pay and
start using it even before the
credit or debit card arrives in
the mail.  Isn't that awesome?
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: It's
pretty cool.  That is pretty
cool.  And so now that we've
taken you through this whirlwind
tour of everything that's been
happening since
we were last up here, which has
been dizzying, and it's the
things that are
making it easier, simpler, and
more rewarding for our users to
pay online and in stores, let's
talk about the
specific ways in which you all
here can create great
experiences for your
customers online and in stores.
So let's STARTD start with
online.
What I really like about online
is its scale.  There are
millions and millions of
merchants all around the world
where you can buy things online.
And we want to make every single
one
of those check-out experiences
great.
So that means that we need
solutions that scale.  And
ideally, they are solutions
where
you don't have to do anything or
just do very little.  Chrome
autofill is one of those
experiences.
Chrome autofill removes the
hassle from users of having to
type in credit card numbers,
shipping addresses and billing
addresses.  It makes it super
simple.
So hopefully your site already
works
perfectly with Chrome autofill,
but we know there's a number out
there that don't.  So we want to
make sure that your users are
able to take advantage of
autofill as fast as possible.
And we've published a set of
guidelines and best practices
that will
enable you to test and optimize
your
check-out forms for Chrome
autofill.
To learn more, go to G.
co/pay/autofill.  Or when you
exit out of here, visit our
sandbox right across the way and
speak with our engineers about
how you
can optimize your check-out flow
.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: So if we
focused exclusively on autofill,
we would be doing Google users a
disservice.  The north star here
is really to skip the check-out
form all together.
And that's where the Google Pay
APIs
for checkout come in.  Now we
announced the online payment
APIs last year, but since then,
we made three major enhancements
that I'd like
to talk to you about
.  FWHURNL
Number one, we're announce ing
ing JavaScript bindings for the
Google Pay check-out.  You can
provide the great experiences
that Google Pay provides across
all browsers.
And a very consistent JSON
representation of request and
response objects.
If you implement the Google Pay
APIs
for check-out for web in
JavaScript, you can easily port
that, including the
payment processing to your app,
and also to Google Assistant.
I actually want to show you a
quick
demo here -- not a demo, but a
screen
share of what we've done with
Fandango that's coming soon
where you can get an
easy check-out experience from
Google
Search when you use a Google Pay
APIs for check-out.
So a user searches for tickets
on Google.
com and they go to the Fandango
site
where they can easily select and
purchase tickets using Google
Pay.  So very exciting.
And the last thing, last
enhancement
that I'd like to talk about is
we've enhanced our readytoPay
API.
You can tell whether a user
enters -- a customer on your
site if they have a payment
method that you can actually
accept.  What this allows you to
do is now that you know this is
a ready to pay user,
you can really streamline the
check-out experience and really
drive increased conversions.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: Great.
That's pretty cool.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Let's
see this stuff in action.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: It is
cooler when you see it in
action.  Let's turn to the
computer.  Last year when we
were up here, we showed you the
great check-out
experience that we created on
the web,
but it was limited to Chrome on
Android.  We have now extended
this to many
other browsers such as safari
such as
desktop and iOS, firefox, etch,
and internet explorer are coming
soon.
And you will be able to play
with this yourselves right after
this slide.  I'm on our demo
site.
Time to get new Google gear.  I
like the shell.  So I go to the
product details page
and I see a "buyBuy With Google
Pay" button.  Over 60% of online
purchases are really just for
one item.
So why put users through a
multi-step check-out flow where
they have to add to a cart and
the other steps?
Let's just let them buy what
they want directly from product
details.  When I click there,
because I was
already logged into my Google
account,
checking Gmail or YouTube, I'm
automatically logged in.
I see the payment methods that I
have saved to my Google account
and other information such as my
shipping address.
And then I hit continue, and
Voila, I am done.  It's that
simple.  Okay?
So, that's cool.  But on
Chrome, we're doing something
even more cool in the near
future.
So on Chrome, we are creating a
near
native experience that is fast
and seamless and tightly
integrated into Chrome.
As you can see right here, when
I move my window around, things
stay in place.  And this is
really great.  Let's turn it
back to the slides, please.
So if you want to check this out
yourselves on your iPhone or on
your desktop, go to G.
co/pay/webdemo.
So fewer distractions, faster
check-out, simpler check-out
means greater conversion.  And
we're pretty confident that
you're going to see these types
of results when
you implement the Google Pay
API.
Since we announced Google Pay,
the response from merchants has
been overwhelming all around the
world.
We've added merchants such as
Uber and
Doordash, Asos, Deliveroo, and
soon coming? Starbucks.
And our partners are seeing
great results.
StubHub, for example, since
they've implemented the newest
version of our API has seen a 7X
increase in
transactions through Google Pay,
and air
BnB saw an 11% increase in
transactions through Google Pay.
And it's interesting and great
that
Hotel Tonight has found that
users that
use Google Pay to complete a
booking are
65% more likely to complete the
transaction than those who
don't.  Varouj, tell us more.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: If you
guys take one thing away from
I/O on the payment
side, you should definitely
figure out how you're going to
implement these
Google Pay APIs for Check-Out on
your surfaces to give your
customers incredible payment
experiences.  We have two
additional sessions that you can
go to.
The first is tomorrow, what's
new for online check-out on
stage 6.  And the second is by
our UX team.  It's called the
Google Pay best practices for
great payment experiences.
And that's on stage 7 on
Thursday.
So please go and check those
out.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: Great.
Let's talk next about something
that users love more than saving
time.  Saving money.  Who
doesn't love to save money?
So, Google Pay is more than just
a way
to pay
.  We've invested heavily into
making Google Pay a platform by
which you can engage your users
through loyalty and offers.
In previous years, we've been up
here
and we talked about our
smartSmart Tap protocol, based
on NFC,
which allows users who are in
store to tap once and convey
their loyalty credentials and
offers along with payment
information.  It's a great
experience, and merchants
all around the world have been
implementing Smart Tap and
creating great value-added
check-out experiences for their
users.
So I'm excited to announce today
that
Russia
's Sberbank is the latest
partner that
will be rolling out Smart Tap
across thousands of users in
Russia.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Burr we But
we're not stopping there.  We're
working with tickets as well.
We have an incredible demo today
that we have done with our
partners at Ticket Master that
brings everything together into
one demo.  So, let's go to the
film.
So you'll have to use your
imagination here.
Let's all pretend you're in
Orlando.  Excuse the humidity.
And I'm a massive soccer fan,
and my
favorite team is the Chicago
Fire of the MLS.
So Chicago Fire is visiting
Orlando
city, and I really want to check
out
this game with Gerardo.
I'm going to open the Ticket
Master app, and since they're my
favorite team, it will be in
favorites.
So now I select the game
.  I select a ticket
.  Do "Buy Now.
"
And here we see the "buy with
Google
Pay button," so I'll give that a
click
.  And complete check-out.
Boom.  I've purchased these
tickets.
[ Applause ]
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: It gets
better, though.  It gets better.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: What's
that?
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: It gets
better.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Oh yeah, it
gets better.  Yeah.  Now I can
view these tickets.
And here we see the save to
phone buttons that Gerardo
mentioned.
So I can save this
ticket to Google Pay.
So now, let's open the Google
Pay app
.  When I go to the cards, I now
notice
that I have my tickets here for
Orlando
SC versus Chicago Fire, and I'm
all ready to go to this game.
I'm super excited.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: Get your
gear on.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: And
here's the
kicker -- no pun intended -- I
can actually go to the gate to
get into the game, and I don't
need to fiddle around with paper
tickets and I don't need to scan
QR codes.  All I need to do --
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: Let's turn
it to the demo.  Thank you.
[ Beeping ].
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Tap, and
I gain
entry into the stadium.
[ Applause ]
And I go along my way.  These
are the incredible user journeys
that we can create together with
these
APIs
.  Back to the slides
.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: Okay.
That was great.  Now that we've
overloaded you with information
about all the great things that
you can do with Google Pay, what
are next steps?
So, the first one is super
easy, because it just takes a
few steps.  You exit out this
door and you head over to our
sandbox, and there you can meet
with the engineers that have
built all of these amazing
things.
You can get your questions
answered.  You can get demos.
And some of the demos EECHB get
even get you cookies, and I'm
not
talking browser cookies, but
real tasty, good cookies.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: I'm getting
hungry.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: There are
several deep dives the rest of
this week into the different
things that we talked about
today.  First of all, I would
encourage you to
go check out tomorrow night at
6:30 on
this stage the what's new for
online
checkNew For Online Checkout
session, which is going to be
run by our engineers that have
built all of these amazing
things.  And then on Thursday,
our payments UX
team is going to be doing a
session on
Best Practices forFor Creating
Great Check-out Flows.  They
will go a lot deeper and beyond.
And then finally, on Thursday
afternoon, right near here on
stage 5,
you can learn about how you can
add transactional capabilities
to your actions.
>> VAROUJ CHITILIAN: So if
you can't make these sessions or
the sandbox or if you're
watching on live stream and you
want to learn more, these are
some of the resources you can go
to.  G.
co/pay/autofill.  G.
co/pay/business will give you an
overview.  And if you are a
developer, please go to g.
co/pay/developers to get to the
Google
Pay recommendations directly.
So, I want to say thank you to
all
of the developers and the
developer
community in the room.
Really these payment experiences
are a partnership between us.
We can't provide these payment
experiences to your customers
without you, and so thank you
very much for coming today.  And
thank you for working with us in
developing these incredible
experiences together with Google
Pay.  Thank you.
>> GERARDO CAPIEL: Thank you
very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We'll be making room for those
who
have registered for the next
session.  If you have registered
for the next session in this
room, we ask you to clear the
room and return via the
registration room outside.
Thank you.
RAW FILE
Google I/O
Introducing app domain names and
how to secure them
May 8, 2018
4:00 PM PDT
Stage 6
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
800-825-5234
www.captionfirst.com
***
This text is being provided in a
realtime format.  Communication
Access Realtime translation
(CART) or captioning are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
>> Welcome. Please fill in
the seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: So good
afternoon.
Today we're going be
introduceing .
app domain names.
I'm Ben McIlwain, and I'm the
lead
developer
engineer at Google registry.
>> ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: I'm
Adrienne Porter Felt, and I'm a
long time
engineer on the Google Chrome
team.  About a year ago, Ben
came to my team and I with an
idea.  He worked on the registry
team, and they had an idea that
they were going to be launching
this TLD, top-level domain to
make
memorable and meaningful domain
names.  I'm sure many of you
like short meaningful domain
names.  We also like them in
terms of usability of the web.
We think that URLs are easier to
use if the domains are something
that people
can actually remember, and
ideally differentiate between
the real brands when they're
trying to actually get to
that website, versus other
content that
might be spam, phishing or
spoofing.
But that wasn't all.
Ben was aware of the fact
that
Google has been pushing on
HTTPS adoption to make the web
safer.  It keeps our users'
content private and secure.
HTTPS provides encryption
between the client and the
server, such that anyone
in the middle like the ISP or
someone
else on the same wireless
network isn't
able to eves drop on the
information while on transit or
modify it.
And pushing out HTTPS adoption
has been a big effort across
Google and the security
community for the past several
years.
Back in early 20 #15RKS which15,
we saw that only a quarter to a
third of pages loaded in Chrome
were HTTPS.
At that point
, HTTP was dominant.  Now about
75% of all page loads in
Chrome are RTS HTTPS, so we've
seen a huge shift.  Now we're
looking at how to get the
last little chunk.
Looking back at 2014, Google
premiered HTTPS ranking boothing
inging
boost, so the idea was that
sites would
get bumped if they encrypt
.  Free HTTPS
certificates launched, and
helped a lot of sites get
online, particularly websites
where the developers were not
able to previously afford
certificates.
Even though at 10, $15 was
cheap, some were not able to
afford it.
Google started indexing HTTPS
sites by
default, meaning if a site was
available on both, we would
index the HTTPS version.  We
released a transparency report
showing that at the time only a
quarter
of the top 100 sites supported
HTTPS by default, and now it's
at 83.  Also, near and dear to
my heart, starting in 2017,
Chrome started
labeling HTTP websites as not
secure in
the URL bar if they had a
password, form fields or a
credit card form field, because
those are particularly sensitive
field types.
We ratcheted that up a bit and
in mid 2017, we started labeling
more pages as
not security if they had any
HTTP page
in incognito or any HTTP page
with form fields on it.
And starting in Chrome 68 in
July, all HTTP pages will be
labeled as "not secure" in the
URL bar.
Ben was aware of this and
excited as was the rest of his
team.  They wanted to bring
these two things together, a
product that encourages
memorable domain name as well as
security features of HTTPS.  So
Ben, tell them what the idea
was.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: All right
.  Today we are launching the
world's
first entirely secure all HTTPS
open top-level domain, and I
know that's a lot to unpack.
First, what's a top-level
domain? Let's look at that.  So
a top-level domain is the last
part of the domain name, right
of the final dot.  Top-level
domains are run by registries
like Google registry, that's my
team, for instance.
That's in contrast to a domain
name
registrar which is where you
would go to buy a domain.
The registries run their own
TLD, and that TLD is only run by
that registry.
So you don't interact with the
registries too much, but we're
the big database behind these.
Let's go through examples.
Really obvious ones, .
com, .net, and .org.
Next up, we have the sponsored
TLDs.  These have restrictions
on registration, and these ones
have been out for a very long
time. .
EDU, .
gov, and .mil.  And the third
level would be country
code like .
uk
,.
de, and .io.
It's a country domain name
because it's two letters.
IO is Indian ocean, if you
didn't know.
And finally we get to the most
recent ones, the new generic
TLDs.
So we have .
ho
, and .Google.
These three examples happen to
be ones
run by my team at the Google
registry.
One interesting thing to notice
is dot
the middle one on the bottom is
a unicode.
And, in addition to all of these
existing ones and thousands of
others
that already exist, today,
specifically as of 9:00 a.m.
this morning, there is a new
top-level domain on the web, and
that top-level domain is .app.
So yeah.  Today --
[ Cheers and Applause ]
Thank you.  So yeah.
Introducing .app.  It is the new
home on the web for
mobile apps, web apps,
progressive web
apps, desktop apps, app
developers, and pretty much
anything you can imagine having
to do with apps.
We envision landing pages,
server endpoints, marketing
pages, deep-linking
URLs that go specifically into a
specific piece of content and
pretty much anything else.
It is open, so anyone can buy a
.app domain name.
Because the string is dot app,
it would probably make sense to
use it for
something SOERNT associated with
dot app.
You should all pay attention to
the rest of this talk, because
everyone here is getting a free
.app domain name.  And not just
everyone in this room,
but every single attend eye of
ee of I/O.
Please don't do that right
now.  Please pay attention to
the rest of the presentation.
We're going to give you some
useful tips on how to use them
and most importantly, how to
secure them.
All right.
And then this is our launch site
, GIT.
app.
This is where you would get
yours if you want one or if
you're on the live
streamget.app.  This is where
you would get yours if you want
one or if you're on the live
stream.  And there is a list of
sites that are already live on .
app domains.
>> ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: .app
provides domains that are
memorable because they're short
and there are lots of names
available.  And also, they're
all HTTPS.
Any site registered under .
app needs to be HTTPS.  So the
main reason why I expect
developers and marketers and all
of you here in the room to get
excited is because you can get
short, memorable
domains that tie in with your
brands
.  Since it's a new TLD, it's a
fresh name space.  There are
lots of good names available.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: Although
maybe not
for much longer, because if you
wait too long.  Just since
launch this morning,
there's already been over
100,000 registrations, including
30,000 in just the first three
minutes.
>> ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: My team
snapped one up this morning.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: My team was
very hectic this morning.
>> ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: So, you
know, previously if you were
trying to
work in a .com world, you may
have ended up with a
long domain name, but shorter
ones are
more appealing to developers and
also to end users who have to
remember how to get back to your
website.
But not only are .app names
memorable, but also unique.
This is really important.
Let's say you're trying to get
to this call app.
This is a pretty poplar call
app, particularly in emerging
markets.
And the thing about the name
"call app," is if you searched
for that name,
lots of applications use the
word "call", so there's
ambiguity.
Domain names are unique there's
only one call.app.  So domain
names are a more reliable way
for people to be able to find
your
app, your web app, your mobile
app, whatever, by name.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: All right. So
let's look at some real, live
examples of websites that are
already serving on .app.  As we
go through these, I'm going to
pay particular attention to the
domain names that they're using
and think about
what alternatives may have
existed on older TLDs.
And spoiler alert, the other
alternatives would not have been
as good as these are.
So first up is cash.app.
Obviously a great domain name.
This is an app by Square, and it
is
for sending and receiving money
.  For what they are doing, you
can't
imagine a better name.
Next is ov.app.  They are a
supporting apparel retailer with
an augmented reality shopping
feature in their app.  And then
there's Albert.
app, a financial advice app.
You get a nice, short domain
name that's exactly the actual
name of your app.  And there's
many, many more.  We won't go
through these individually, but
these are all more examples of
real, live apps that are
currently out there and running
on .
app domain names, and you can
find this list on get.app if
you're interested.
We talked about how the
string is interesting, but what
else is special besides the
name? Adrienne mentioned earlier
that security was a big win for
.app.
>> ADRIENNE PORTER FELT:
Security is why I'm excited, but
.app is all HTTPS by default.
If you register and use, you
will need
to build an HTTPS website from
the start.
This idea first came up on the
Chrome
security team
.  It turns out a lot as changed
since then.  And you know, we're
in the future and the future is
awesome and very friendly to
HTTPS.
Don't just take my word for it.
To quote buzz feed, moving to
HTTPS is clearly the way forward
for the industry overall.  And
as I mentioned earlier, at the
beginning, we are seeing three
quarters of page loads now over
HTTPS.  I think most new sites
as they're coming online are all
HTTPS.
Now, I'm excited about HTTPS for
many reasons, but I want to tell
you why you all should be
excited about HTTPS.  It gives a
lot of positive benefits to your
website.
The first is authenticity.  What
this example is showing here on
the screen is someone I know
named Eric Mill browsing on a
wireless hot spot, looking at
the website for the federal
trade commission.
Now normally, the FDC website
does not
have ads all over it, by the
nature that they are a
government website.  But when he
was looking at it, all of this
area that is covered in yellow
was showing advertisements.
They really took up a large
chunk of the view port.  What
was happening is the wireless
hot spot provider was injecting
advertisements for one of their
other
businesses on to every HTTP
service.
This is a thing that ISP,
wireless hot
spots do in order to monetize
there's a
good amount of HTTP traffic that
has advertisements injected.
I'm sure a lot of you in the
room put effort into what your
website looks like.  You think
hard on when and how you should
show advertisements and how it
affects experience.
I'm sure you don't want someone
else's ads all over your
beautiful website.  If you have
an HTTPS domain, this kind of
thing can't happen.
Another thing that HTTPS
gives you is access to powerful
APIs.
New web features that have come
out over the past few years are
available only to HTTPS
websites.  This is particularly
important for
people making PWAs, or
progressive web apps.  Service
workers which are important
for building good offline
experiences,
background syncing and sending
push notifications are
important.
Geonotification, camera and mic
are HTTPS only.
Also, if you have an HTTPS
website,
you'll get a better look in a
Chrome URL bar.
In July 2018, which is the
Chrome 68 release, all HTTP
websites will be marked not
secure.  Right next to the
domain name in the URL bar.  So,
you know, we're trying to tell
users what you get with HTTP,
which is
an unencrypted insecure
connection.  If any of you here
are running websites that are
not HTTPS yet, please
move them to HTTPS before July.
Also, as an added bonus.
Android security is important,
too.
It requires TLS by default to
prevent anyone from messing with
or looking at
the traffic between people's
Android phones and your back
ends, so you will need to have
that set up anyway.
We're using a technique called
HTed
HSTS preload
ing HSTS stands for HTTP strict
transport SKURTD security.  I
tried to say the whole thing
earlier, and it takes like five
minutes.
So what HSTS does is it's a way
for your server to tell the
browser that your web content
should be always over HTTPS.
So you would send a header
that's
named strict transport security,
and once the browser sees that,
it will note to only connect
over HTTPS from then on
until the max age runs out
without seeing an updated max
age.  Even if the user doesn't
specify the scheme and they type
in the URL bar, or
if the user types in HTTP or
clicks on
an HTTP link, they will end up
on an HTTPS version of your
website.
-HSTS prevents a downgrade
attack on your website.
If you have both an HTTP verse
and
HTTPS, it's possible to force
users back to the HTTP version
if you don't haves is like HSTS.
Let me explain with an example.
Fairly recently, the citizen lab
claimed that middle boxes on the
telecom
network we redistrict
directing to spy ware.  They
supported HTTPS, but were not
HTTPS only, they were not using
HSTS.  So the ISP was able to
force the connections down to
HTTP and modify them in transit.
So using HSTS will prevent that
from
happening
.
Plus you can go one step further
with something called
preloading.  There's a long list
of domains that
want you to be always HTTPS even
on that very first connection
before the browser has had a
chance to see a header.  If
you're on this list, then the
browser knows that the
connection should always be over
HTTPS, even without
having seen that header.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: All right.
In addition to preloading
individual
domain names in the HTTPS list,
it's
also possible to preload an
entire top-level domain.  That's
exactly what we did and how we
implemented this security
features of .app.  So this
screen shot right here is just a
screen shot from the actual GIT
repository that's hosting the
HSTS
preload list, and these TLDs are
on it.  What that means is that
any web request through a
browser to any domain
on any of these
top-level domains will have the
URL upgraded from HTTP to HTTPS
before that network connection
is ever made.
So it's always and only ever
HTTPS to
any domain on those TLDs.
There's a company called FTLD
registry, and they run .bank and
.insurance.  You can see why
security would be important in
those industries.  There's more
coming soon to this list,
and we would encourage registry
operators to add more.  Out of
the eight that are currently on
there now, .
app is the first open TLD on the
list.  What that means is it's
the first one on the list that
grants security benefits to
everyone here present, because
you can all and indeed you all
do now have a free .app domain
name.
It TEES's the first time that
this benefit is being made
available to everyone.  And you
get it just by registering a
domain name.
Why has this not happened before
now? There's a couple reasons.
One is that the requisite
browser
support for handle inging
top-level pre-loading came in
only fairly recently.
And that really easily HTTPS
configuration and one-click SSL
certificate provisioning came
out and
made it really simple to just
get that hosting working.
And a lot of that is thanks to
lets encrept.  And another
reason we're doing this now is
because privacy and security is
on everyone's minds these days.
It's in the news constantly.
Enforced HTTPS is something that
can help mitigate some of these
issues.  You can't have privacy
and security at
all if you're doing things over
an insecure connection or a
connection that can be forced to
be insecure.  It's just not even
possible.
There's a huge number of
different benefits of preloading
at the TLD level that I'd like
to go over.
So number one
, it eliminates configuring
headers.  You will never need to
go stack
overfloeflow or Google and
figure out
how to get HTTPS on Apache.
It's already done on the entire
top-level domain.
And, there's no need to submit
your
domain to the HSTS preload list,
which would otherwise be another
step you would have to do to get
that security benefit.
And very importantly, by having
the entire TLD already on the
HSTS preload list, and we did
this last year, it eliminates
the lag time to add domains to
the preload list.  If you went
out right this second and bought
a .com domain name, and you
wanted to
adhere to the best possible web
security practices and submitted
to the HSTS list right now, it
would take many months for many
users to get the advantage of
the higher level security.  The
reason for that is the browser
release cycle.  Go into the code
now, hit the nightly, and in a
month and a half it would hit
the beta and then in a month and
a half,
hit the GA, and eventually
people would
update their browser and get the
benefit.  But here you get the
security instantly.
And very importantly, preloading
a TLD increases browser
efficiency.
Because the preload list is
built into every browser
installation, it's in the
downloaded executable both on
desktop
and mobile in every
installation.  So there's over 2
billion Chrome installations out
there, and there's
many billions of installations
of other browsers and the HSTS
preload list is in every one of
them.  Keeping the list small
and efficient is very important,
because it's saving a lot of
disk space and memory on all of
these different computers and
mobile devices.  And especially
important for the
mobile devices is a smaller list
is more efficient to check
against, because there's fewer
entries to check when you're
making a web request, so it's
saving CPU cycles too, and
that's obviously very important
on mobile.
If you use more CPU cycles,
you're using up more battery.
And preloading makes your
site faster.  If you're not
preloading and you want to have
security, what you typically do
is you will have an HTTP to
HTTPS redirect.
So users will type in the
domain, and
by default, an HTTP request will
be main, then a redirect, and
another request to the HTTPS
site.
By not having the redirect,
which you can accomplish by
preloading, you are
saving a round trip to the
server.  This is significant on
mobile devices, especially on
spotty connections.  You can
easily save at least a
connection by loading the secure
version of the site first and
immediately rather
than hitting the whole redirect.
And another benefit, preloading
makes URLs shorter without
losing safety.
For marketing you want short
URLs, obviously whether it's
print materials
or web ads or radio commercials
or telling your friend the name
of a domain name.  You're not
going to say I found this
cool app it's HTTPS
://name of app blah blah blah
blah.
If it's preloaded, the request
is upgraded to HTTPS without
having to include the protocol
specifier.  This makes marketing
and security people happy.
So a really simple example is
which looks better? Which would
you rather see on, let's
say maybe a sticker
? HTTPS://get.app? Or just get.
app? And because it's preloaded,
it's just
as secure as the one on the
left.
>> ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: So
maybe you guys are already an
old hat at setting up HTTPS
websites, but just in case, we
will walk through tips on how to
set up an HTTPS website and
tools that are available for you
to use.  Of course, the first
thing you need is a certificate.
Sometimes people have a
perception that certificates are
going to be expensive,
particularly wild cards.  You
can get free certificates from
lets encrypt.
There are crowd engines that
will provision a free
certificate for you if you're a
customer.
Not only does your top-level
frame need to be HTTPS, but all
of the sub resources within that
frame need to be
HTTPS, meaning your scripts,
images, iFrames.  They all need
to be HTTPS as well.  It's
called a mix content error if
you
have a mix of HTTP and HTTPS
resources on a page.
And this is problematic for your
website.  If you have active
resources like a
script or an iFrame that are
HTTP, browsers will block them
on an HTTPS connection, and they
will not show up.  If you have
passive content like an image,
it will show up but not ideal.
You will usually get a downgrade
to tell people that not all of
the sub resources have been
loaded correctly.  So it's
really important that you're
testing for this, looking out
for mixed content, that you're
able to move your sub resources
to HTTPS, too.
One tool you can use is
actually built into Chrome.
Hopefully all of you in the room
use Chrome.
Assuming you do, you can look in
dev tools and open up the
security panel.
This is showing a test website,
mixed.badssl.com.
It shows any origins for
requests so you can get them
fixed.
Another tool is lighthouse.
Lighthouse provides audits.  One
of them is a security audit that
looks for mixed content.
In this example, which is again
mix.badssl.
com, it tells you about all of
the insecure resources that it
found on the page that you can
fix.
It also highlights the one that
you can tell are already
available over HTTPS.  So for
those, you'll just need to go
add an extra S into the resource
request and you're golden.
For others you may need to use a
different sub domain.  Sometimes
things have a special secure
or S sub domain they use for
HTTPS traffic.  Or if it's a
company that you are paying, you
may need to specifically specify
in your contract that you want
to use HTTPS version of their
sites.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: All right.
So, number three is use HTTPS in
your
development environment and
indeed, all environments.  Don't
just wait until production.
There's many reasons for this.
One is the powerful web APIs
that Adrienne was talking about.
Some of them you can hit
insecurely over local content.
Iftext.  If you want to show
them over your local network to
your colleagues, it will not
work without an SSL certificate.
There are third-party web APIs
that
require HTTPS, and you cannot
test unless you're supporting
it.  Another problem is, if you
are doing a
mix of HTTP in development and
HTTPS
later, you have two different
canonical resources.  You could
easily get them confused.
There's a whole class of
problems you can cause for
yourself that are completely
unnecessary by not having that
one canonical location for all
resources that only starts with
HTTPS.
And third, it's maybe sort of
tautological, but you need to
use HTTPS in your dev
environment so that you can test
HTTPS.  It doesn't make sense to
wait until the very last minute
right before you want to go to
production and change everything
and now make it secure, because
a lot of things are going to
start breaking right then, most
likely
mixed mode content errors.
If you're going to be running it
securely, you need to be testing
it securely so problems don't
creep up on you.
And number four, when testing
use a real domain or sub domain
that you own.  Or do not use a
fake domain or sub domain that
you don't own.  It's the same
thing repeated twice, so it's
important so I'm emphasizing it.
The reason is simple.  Why use a
real domain? If you use a fake
domain, you are going
to have problems.  Not maybe,
it's almost guaranteed.  The
specific problem is a name
collision where traffic is
unexpectedly going somewhere
that you didn't want it to go.
It will work fine on my
computer, but
in any other contacts like let's
say I run a new docker container
and forgot set up a new DNS,
it's going to a completely
different location or a friend
runs it and it's going to a new
location.
You're not in charge of your
destiny if you are using a fake
domain name.  This is a huge
problem if you're interacting
with third-party web services.
Huge numbers of developers
worldwide have had problems when
they used a fake domain or a
domain on a fake TLD only for it
to turn out to be real or later
become real, which is sort of
even worse because things break
on you later.  When you use a
fake domain, you're not in
control of your own destiny.
At Google registry, we run 46
TLDs, and we know how big of a
problem this is, because we get
an unbelievable amount of
misaddressed traffic to what are
supposedly fake domain names
that are actually real.  And to
really drive that home, two of
the 46 TLDs that we run are .dev
and .prod.  If you are using
domain names like that, stop
immediately, because those are
real and we're getting some of
that traffic.
>> ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: I see
some guilty faces.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: Some guilty
people in the audience here.
Here's a simple example of the
right way to do things.
So use a real domain name.  And
then get a wild card certificate
for all sub domain names.
You can do that for free with
lets encrypt.
And depending on if you want
local DNS
resolution, you can use etsy
host file.
Or you can use something like
DNS mask.  The reason is you
obviously don't want
to route traffic worldwide to
your local dev set up when it's
not ready.  You only want it to
resolve locally.  But the key
thing is it's still a real
domain name, so you are in
charge of where that traffic
will go from the world, and you
know it's never going anywhere
unexpectedly, so therefore never
in name collisions.
And the final tool for doing
secure
hosting is just use a service
with automatic HTTPS.
And there's so many of them
these days.
Some examples, Google AppEngine,
Firebase
, GitHub pages and many, many
more.
This is a system simple way to
get a secure site running.
Many times it's as simple as
hitting a check box.
Sometimes it's even simpler,
because
the check box is checked by
default.
You combine a hosting service
that
gives you automated security
with a .
app domain, and when you have
those two combined, you have the
best in class,
best possible best practices
security.
>> ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: Some
some of you may be moving
existing websites over to .app.
Keep in mind that assuming you
want to maintain your search
ranking, help out the Google
BOT.  It needs to know that
you're moving your domain so you
maintain your ranking from one
domain through to the other.
There's an excellent search
console help article that walks
you through the best practices.
There's an FAQ that covers what
you need to do to prepare for a
site move.  I strongly encourage
you take a look at that if you
ever move a website.
I'm going to pause because I see
a whole bunch of people taking
pictures of the slide.  All
right.
The help center has other tips
on
practices for making your HTTPS
setting set up be ranking
friendly.
I encourage you to check this
out, too.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: So one last
final reminder, the launch site
is get.app.  All the relevant
information is there, or look at
the sticker on the back of your
laptop, hopefully.  And everyone
here in attendance, go and get
your free domain.  Follow the
instructions in the e-mail.  For
anyone that's not here or on the
live stream or people here who
want more than one .app,
hopefully the same.  And the
last note, and this is very
important is you should go out
there and use these domain
names.  Don't just register them
and park them.  The security
comes from using them.  Security
is getting more and more
people on HTTPS on the web and
getting more of them on the best
possible
practices domains that are HSTS
preloaded.  Do it on .
app because security is easier
on .app than anywhere else.  All
right.
So thank you very much.
Here is some social information
and links to check out.
The last one
is nomulus.
foo.
It is what we use to run all 46
of our top-level domains,
including .app.
If you had any curiosity of how
top-level domains are run, you
can go to nomulus.
foo, and it goes to our GitHub
to see our source code.  We are
running out of time, but we will
be in the web biodome G over
there, so come talk to us
afterwards.
>> ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: Thanks,
everyone.
>> BEN MCILWAIN: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with
directing you through the
designated exits.  We'll be
making room for those who
registered for the next session.
If you've registered for the
next session in this room, we
ask that you
please clear the room and return
via the registration line
outside.  Thank you.
LOIP
good afternoon, everyoneGood
afternoon, everyone.
>> I'm responsible for improving
our
understanding of Android apps,
their
capabilities, content and
attributes.
>> ILYA FIRMAN: Hi, everyone.
I'm a software engineer on the
actions on Google team.
Actions on Google offers APIs
for developers to integrate with
the Google assistant and other
Google products.
My focus is on connecting
Android apps
into the actions on Google
system.
>> LUV KOTHARI: As Dave
mentioned in
the keynote this morning, app
actions
will allow users to discover and
re-engage with the capabilities
and
content of apps at just the
right moment.  You will get an
opportunity to increase reach
and engagement for your
apps across multiple Google and
Android surfaces.  Let's look at
a couple of examples for this.
With app actions, users will be
able to get things done quickly
and seamlessly.  Imagine you're
planning a Friday night out with
your friends.  Wouldn't it be
great if you had a personal
assistant which would help you
accomplish tasks such as making
a dinner
reservation, getting movie
tickets, getting a ride to the
venue, and building a collage
from the pictures taken during
the evening.
Google assist TANLT was
ant was created to help users
with these many tasks.  And for
these tasks, the user may have
the perfect Android app on their
devices.
With app actions, your Android
app can integrate with the
Google assistant and
participate in these user
journeys.  MOFR, the app
suggestions will appear on
Google and Android surfaces to
help users get things done and
discover what their apps can do.
With app actions, user will
be able to go from the content
they love to the
actions that can take on that
content to the relevant apps to
fulfill those actions.
Imagine a lady Gaga fan is
searching for her latest hits.
Wouldn't it be great if that
user, while looking for that
information could also discover
where to listen to her songs,
watch her videos, buy tickets to
her upcoming concerts or find
updates about her? This is the
ideal moment for the use tore
discover capabilities of the
Android apps they already have.
App actions can help users
re-engage with the apps they
forgot they had, and also
discover new opportunities and
capabilities they did not know
existed.
We are bringing similar
experiences to diverse content
such as TV shows,
movies, books, courses, sports,
games,
books, and more
.  As an Android developer, you
know that re-engagement is a
challenging problem.  Users have
hundreds of apps on their
devices to choose from.
Android authority did a survey a
couple of years ago and found
that 77%
of Android users do not use an
app after three days of
installing it.
And that number goes up to 90%
after a month.  You all have
worked really hard for
those app installs, but getting
users to keep coming back to
your app is a harder problem.
Notifications and e-mails are
all tools in your tool kit, but
it's also possible that it can
come across as spammy and
annoying.
It's much bet toreter to
re-engage with the user in the
right context and in the right
moment.
So today we're going beyond
simply predicting the next app
the user would
want to open to the next action
the user would want to take.
In an AI-first world, we want to
assist users to find
capabilities and
content from your apps even if
that
information is buried deep
inside the app.  So how will we
make this happen?
First, we are building a
rich
catalog of actions -- or intents
as we call them.
Essentially, think of them of
verb plus noun.
Some examples, play music, play
game,
take course, order ride, order
food.  These are all intents in
our catalog.
For these intents, we will build
deep semantic understanding.
What do I mean by that? We will
define detailed schemas with
parameter specs and define
grammar, not only in English but
many other languages.  Let's
take a concrete exam.
Of checking air quality in Los
Angeles.
There are multiple ways to check
pollution.
Look at these here.  There are
many other possible ways the
user can make that query.
Google will parse all of these
queries
and map them into one common
intent
called
check_air_quality, and pass on
the right parameters so they
will all get passed along to the
Android app, which
will take the user to the right
place inside the app and get the
correct action.
We also define grammars in
popular
languages and provide natural
language understanding.  You get
instant global reach without
having to do the hard work of
understanding languages.  We
already support 16 languages and
will continue to expand that
coverage.
How do you participate?
As an Android developer, you
need to add an actions.
xml file
into your APK
.  Once you have exposed the
capabilities and content of your
apps, Google will map user
queries and context
to your app and service you
highly utilized products within
Android in the
launcher and selection, the GOOL
Play store, the Google
assistant, and the search app.
Actions are not restricted to
Android P, and are available on
all devices with
the most recent versions of
these appsoogle play store, the
Google assistant, and the search
app.  Actions are not restricted
to Android P, and are available
on all devices with the most
recent versions of these apps.
Let's walk through a few
examples, and I'm very excited
to be walking you through these.
This is my screen on my phone,
an all app screen.
Last year we introduced the
concept of predicted
apps.  It has been working
really great.  As Dave mentioned
this morning, we have about 60%
prediction rate on this.  It's
phenomenal.  This year, we want
to go further.
You want to go from predicting
the next app to predicting the
next action a user would want to
take.  If you take a closer
look, I see two action
suggestions.
And right around this time of
the day
, commuting back home, I'm
relying on Google maps to
navigate me around traffic.
I'm also talking to my wife,
Tina, catching up on her day,
mostly
strategizing how to survive with
two
kids at home
.  Both of these actions take me
deep inside the app.
The actions are predicted based
on my
usage patterns, my routines, my
app sequences and the context
I'm in, whether I'm in my car,
whether I have my
headset on, what is it I'm
doing.
If I rarely plug in my headset
with my
phone, I get an action to resume
a play list I was listening to
in my favorite music app.
Actions are also integrated
in smart text selection in
Android.  Let's say I get a
recommendation to a
new restaurant in a city called
flour+water
.  It will try to map what
possible
actions, and then further, what
possible apps would be needed
for the given entity.
As I select flour +Water, I get
a suggestion to use Open Table.
I can click on that where it
will take me directly to the
open table app where I can see
information, read reviews, and
make the dinner reservation.
All of this is using an on
device machine learning model.
Any of the text that I'm
selecting on
the screen never leaves my
device.  Everything is secure
and fast.
Smart text selection will be
able to recognize many entities
such as TV
shows, movies, athletes,
musicians,
flight numbers, and more.
Actions would also surface on
play store.  We all know there
is an app for everything.
And the Play Store is the place
where users go looking for those
apps and those capabilities.
So let's say I search for
ladyLady Gaga, I will get
suggestions to go inside any of
these apps to perform these
actions.  What's interesting is
not only do I get action
suggestions for apps I have
installed, but also the apps I
have not installed.
This is the universe of apps
that exist out there.  If I tap
on something that is not
installed, I will go to the
details page of that app,
install the app, and then I tap
open, and it will take me
directly into the right place
inside the app to fulfill that
action.
With app actions, users can
discover new ways to re-engage
with the content they already
love.
Actions will also work in
assistant.
Let's say I ask Assistant to
show me my budget on mint.  I
will pass it to show_budget
action inside the Android app.
The right placed in the
app will get invoked and I'm
able to fulfill that action.
Here I am asking assistant what
is
lady Gaga's real name, but
assistant anticipates that I
might be interested
in knowing more about lady Gaga
and similar actions.
I get offered more knowledge
chips to listen to her music and
buy tickets to her concert.
It's a great way for users to
discover capabilities about the
apps they already have, and they
are able to do so in the right
moment.  Again, tapping on any
of these chips
will take me directly into your
Android apps and will let me
fulfill the action
I was intending to do.
Finally, as Dave mentioned
thised
mentioned this morning in the
keynote, as an example, if you
search for the
latest avengers movie, "Infinity
War,"
you will get an action to
Fandango app to buy tickets if
you have Fandango installed.
App actions are built as part of
a broader actions in Google
developer platform.
This platform provides common
development tools and processes
and a
set of foundational building
blocks
.
You can provide Google
inventory for your actions.
You can report action usage by
app indexing and get
personalized suggestions based
on usage patterns.
Identity in seamless digital
suggestions allow hassle free
foundations across multiple
modalities.
The two modalities available,
Android
app actions is what we have been
talking about here.  There is
another one, which is
conversation actions, and you
have heard quite a bit about it
in consumer and developer
keynote.  These are ones for you
to build voice-powered
experiences.  You can also
design a vertical program
and deeply integrate with
Google.
You also tell us how to fulfill
intents with deep links
.  Ilya, can you walk us through
some of this and show us how
it's working?
>> ILYA FIRMAN: Thank you so
much
.  I hope you guys are as
excited as we are about the
opportunities offered by app
actions.  You must wonder how do
I sign up.  Let me walk you step
by step through the actions of
setting up your app.
At the core of app actions is
actions.xml, a new configuration
file that you can include in
your Android APK.
It enables you to register for
intents and define fulfillment
for those intents.
When we talk about intents, we
are
talking semantic intents.  These
intents describe what your
action does in the language that
Google can understand
.  Intents can be built in or
custom intents defined by the
developer.  And while intents
describe what an
action does, fulfillment
describes how your app does that
action.
For Android apps, fulfillment
connects the semantic intent to
the Android intent in the app.
Together, intents and
fulfillment
define actions, and actions.xml
is how you provide actions in
your Android app.
Once you define intents and
fulfillment, you can integrate
usage
logging into your app using APIs
from Firebase app indexing.
You can enhance the way actions
are
presented to the user using
slices, a new UI framework.
This is a quick, high-level
overview.  Let us walk through
each step in detail, starting
with intents.
As Luv mentioned earlier, app
actions is built on a new
catalog of
semantic intents published by
Google as part of the actions by
Google catalog.
We define a grammar that helps
us recognize queries, and
parameters we can infer from the
query and pass to your app.  The
catalog helps us organize the
world of actions so we can show
the right actions to the right
user at the right time.
We expect that most will
register for one of our built-in
intents.  With that, you give
Google a deep understanding of
what your app does.
Moreover, with built-in intents
you do
not need to worry about natural
language understanding.
You may want to ask to book a
taxi or order a cab.  With
built-in intents, you don't need
to worry about the different
ways in
which a user can express the
same intent.  Google takes care
of natural language
understanding.  Your app just
needs to provide fulfillment.
Built-in intents give you
support for many languages right
out of the box, and
they provide a one-stop shop for
giving access to multiple UI
surfaces.  Google will be adding
more and more intents to the
catalog over time.  If your
particular use case is not
covered, chances are it will be
soon.  And you will have a way
to request new intents to be
defined.  If your use case is
truly unique, you can define a
custom intent and build
your own grammar, the equivalent
of play console or actions on
Google developers.
It is important to
distinguish with semantic
intents that they are defined on
actions on Google and Android
intents, a feature in the
Android framework.  As Android
developers, you are familiar
with Android intents.  They
describe specific operations in
a way that allows Android apps
to talk to each other.  Semantic
intents are part of our larger
catalog that extends beyond
Android that looks at
assistance, search, and other
surfaces.
For Android apps, actions.
xml is what dedefines the
mapping.
Of course, you can built
multiple ways to build the same
semantic intent across multiple
types of devices.  Let's say
you're a bank and you want
to support the check_account
intent.  You could build a
conversational action so you
could support a voice-only
experience on Google Home or
smart displays, using the tools
you have seen earlier.
And if you would like to
learn more about how to
transition from building
for your Android app to
conversational
experiences, you can come to a
session dedicated to that on
Thursday morning.
Today
Now, if you're an Android
developer, you're probably
familiar with intent filters,
and they expose intents outside
of the app.
Intent builders define content
types
and data URIs, and those can
come in the
form
of HTTP URLs.
It defines how a semantic intent
can
be converted into a
URL to open into your app
.  Now, why do we use URLs to
connect semantic and Android
intents?
Deep link URLs are part of a
larger app discovery eco-system.
You can link your app URLs to
your web
content using verified app links
or site maps.
With Google's structured data
programs, you can precisely
define the specific content that
your app can support.  And with
Firebase app indexing, you
can enable Google to enable
actionable suggestions to
identify what users do when they
use your app.  All of the
different features and
programs use URLs to identify
content in your app.
So we've talked about intents.
Let's switch gears and talk
about fulfillment.
Fulfillment describes a specific
mechanism to invoke a particular
action in your app.  It tells
Google how to determine the
specific deep-link URL to open
for a specific given intent.
You can use one of two models to
provide fulfillment for semantic
intent.
We use the parameters of the
semantic
intent to dynamically conduct at
run
time.  At run time, we take the
parameters
from the user intent and pass
them into your URL.
This model is ideal for
action-centered apps with
deep-link APIs.
In the content-driven model, we
discovered a fulfillment URL
through your web content or
structured data.
We use the query to find the
content
in your web presence and
actions.xml to connect with the
appropriate content.  You must
verify ownership of your content
before you can use it in your
app.  You can use Android's
verified app links or connect
using your website using the
Google search console.
All that's really needed for
fulfillment is linking your
actions.
xml to your web pages, but the
content-driven fulfillment model
works best with structured data.
Structured data can describe the
nouns, the inventory of your
app.  Google provides a variety
of structured data programs.
Some of them use web mark-up,
some of them use hosted data
feeds.  Many of you probably
already participate in these
programs.  You can use the
developer side to see if there's
a vertical program that fits
your specific use case, and you
can find a link to the tool that
you can use to
test your mark-up.  How do you
actually submit your actions.xml
to Google? Perhaps you're
developing in Android
studio and you can include in
the same
APK that you submit to the play
console.
It parses your actions and
registers them in the actions on
Google database.  This
registration allows your app to
respond to queries and appear in
suggestions in various Google
products.  And how can you test
that your actions
work before you submit your app
to Play? You can use our new
plugin for the Android studio
called the app actions test
tool.  With this tool, you can
validate your actions.xml and
submit it to actions on Google
in the special preview mode,
which makes your actions
available just for your own
developer account.
You can then test how Google
assistant
would invoke with different
combinations of semantic intent
parameters.
But enough talk.
In this first example, I
will show you how the URL
template base fulfillment model
works.
I will show you my favorite text
here that I built a couple weeks
ago for this session.
Can we switch the slides for
just one moment? Switch to
slides?
Thank you.
The order write intent comes
with four parameters.  Each of
these parameters is defined as a
schema.org entity.  And you can
see on the slide how we parse
out the parameters of that
entity from a user invocation.
And now let's switch to the
demo.  What you can see on your
screen is Android studio.  Many
my Android project, I have my
actions.xml file open.
You can see here that I'm
registering my taxi app for the
order ride intent,
and I'm providing a URL
template, in
this case it happens to be an
HTTP URL,
but you can use app-specific
URLs or intent URIs.  Here there
are place holders for the
drop-off and pick-up address.
These parameters are mapped to
the parameters of the intent.
Now, let's bring up the app
actions test tool
.  When I click the load actions
button, it will take the
actions.xml, parse it and submit
it to actions on Google in
preview mode.  So I can test
what would happen if I
pass this particular parameter
.  When I click run
-- for some reason my phone
switched to landscape mode, but
I think I made the point.  The
tool passes from the parameter
to the app.  The way this
happens is the tool simulates
what Google assistant would do
if it received a particular
semantic intent with particular
parameters.
More specifically, the tool
constructs an action link.  And
you might have seen action links
earlier today in the actions on
Google talk.
And this is a deep link to a
specific
semantic intent in the
assistant.
Let's switch to slides, please.
We talked about the
template-based fulfillment
model.  Let's talk about how the
content-driven model works.
We have worked with Coursera to
integrate their app actions.
They are setting up with the
take_course intent from our core
catalog.  This takes a specific
parameter of type schema.  You
can see how the properties of
schema.course from a user
invocation.
Now Coursera happens to elevate
their
pages with structured data, and
we can infer what the name of
the course is, what the course
is about, and what the
specific deep link URL for the
course is.
Since Coursera is use ing
verified app links, we can use
it to open on the device.
Let's switch to the laptop,
please.  Thank you.
Here is the actions.xml could
look like for Coursera.
They are signing up for the
take_course intent, and for the
parameter, there is an inventory
reference that ties this
registration to schema.org
course structures located on
these web pages.
And the URL template takes the
URL discovered from structured
data as a refer parameter.
Again, we can bring up the app
actions test tool.
Submit actions in preview mode
.  And let's see what would
happen if I
wanted to study machine learning
.  The Coursera app opens to the
specific deep link for the
machine learning course.
And if the demo Gods smile on
us, perhaps we could see what
would happen
if I try the query, "What is
deep learning?".
So here, Google is giving us --
the system is giving us another
chance to explain what deep
learning is, but under the
answer there is a suggestion to
learn more by taking a course
with Coursera.  And when I click
on that link, it opens a
specific deep link to a course
in the Coursera app.  Switch
back to slides, please.
So you have seen how you can
define
your intents and fulfillment
using the actions.xml file.  You
can further help us discover
your
apps by integrating usage
logging
through your app, using Firebase
app indexing APIs.  Action
logging through Firebase and
indexing helps Google provide
personalized suggestions based
on the context and usage
patterns.
If you often listen to jazz
music on your evening commute,
it will show a
suggestion to play cool jazz
music when you get into the car.
If we know that you keep
watching a show, we can suggest
when the next episode comes out.
Action logging can help the
action suggestions.  This is not
a new API, but we have
made changes to support app
actions.
You can tie to a specific
semantic intent and specific
parameter values.  Users remain
in control of their data at all
times.  They can see and control
all of their logged activity
using their my activity website
and opt out of action logging
all together.
I will now pass the stage to Luv
who will talk to you about how
you can
enhance your actions by adding
rich UI
and conversational fulfillment.
>> LUV KOTHARI: Thank you Ilya
and thank you demo Gods.  This
was incredible.  I want to give
a big shout out to multiple
product teams that have worked
together on this feature.  I
mean, if you imagine, right, you
have Android as a developer
eco-system, and you've got
actions on Google.  It's never
easy when you try to make both
of these eco-systems work
together as seamlessly as you
have just seen here.
To recap, as a developer, you
can participate in actions by
registering
your app and the actions in your
app in your actions.xml file.
You can provide URLs.  You can
report action usage fusing
Firebase app indexing to help
your app rank better.
However, app actions, as we
think of it, is just the first
step in your journey with
actions.
The more ways with which you can
enhance actions and further
increase engagement with users.
First, you can use slices to
enhance
action representation through
rich UI templates.  And you can
build conversational experiences
and multimodality experiences in
the Google eco-system.
Slices enhance presentation
through templates.  These
templates are designed to appear
outside the app in the Android
system
UI, like notifications like
assistant and search.
These templates support flexible
layouts, interactive controls
like
sliders and toggles, like data
realtime pricing served directly
on the app on the user's phone.
Slices are compatible with API
19 or
above and enables you to get to
over 95% of Android devices out
there.  Pretty cool.
This year slices are
launched on Google search on
Android.
We have a whole session
dedicated to
slices norms tomorrow at 8:30 on
stage four.  Hope to see you
there.
What about the new devices
and platforms? Things that you
heard from Brad in the developer
keynote this afternoon? You can
extend your services to new
devices and form factors by
building conversational actions
and multi-modality experiences
for Google Assistant.  Again, to
learn more, please attend our
technical session on Thursday
morning at 10:30 on stage 4.
Actually, it's 9:30.  My bad.
I hope you're as excited about
this project as we can.  Many
Android developers are already
building support for actions and
hope you will as well.  If
you're interested, please let us
know at G.co/appactions.
You can learn more on the page,
and we will be starting an early
access program next month and
hopefully some of you will sign
up for that.  We would love to
hear your feedback, and
specifically on intents and the
catalog we're building for
intents.
Over the next two days, we have
quite a few venues to answer any
burning questions you may have.
We have office hours and in both
sandboxes in Android as well as
Assistant where we can show you
these things live and answer any
questions you may have.
We have two more sessions, one
on
slices and one on actions the
day after tomorrow.  And you
will be able to upload the
actions.
xml file on your app use
ing the Play console.  Thank you
so much.
[ Applause ]
>> LUV KOTHARI: Thank you.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Brand ambassadors will assist
with directing you through the
designated exits.  We'll be
making room for those who
registered for the next session.
If you've registered for the
next session in this room, we
ask that you
please clear the room and return
via the registration line
outside.  Thank you.
RAW FILE
Google I/O
Designing for inclusion:
Insights from John Maeda and
Hannah Beachler
May 8, 2018
6:00 PM PDT
Stage 6
Services provided by:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
800-825-5234
www.captionfirst.com
***
This text is being provided in a
realtime format.  Communication
Access Realtime translation
(CART) or captioning are
provided in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
***
that --
I don't
-- you know what I seem saying?
It is as important as creating
an app
or creating something, you know,
having the voices there that has
the experience in those
communities, because you really
don't know what you don't know.
That's what I learned by going
to Africa.  You don't know what
you don't know, but I knew I was
going to look at it with beauty.
I knew I was going to look at it
with the lens of absolute
modernism and
beauty and capability, all the
things
that I wanted to put into
Panther.  I wasn't looking for
the commercial with the
poverty-stricken children.  I
wasn't looking for the things
that we're told the continent
is.  I was looking for the joy
and pride and dignity of the
people that lived there.
And, you know, that's the choice
we make for wherever we are,
because I met people who lived
in the rural parts of
Africa just as much as people
lived in
the modern cities like Johan
asburg, Durbin, Cape Town.  You
could see someone dressed in
tradition
al Zulu in the city just as much
as you might see that in rural
areas.
So I decided not only to find
myself
and realized that I think I have
been
African this entire time, but
that was
determined to find all the
beautiful
things that I was told weren't
there.  That, then really came
back to who I am as a person,
you know what I mean? It related
back to who I am and how I felt
about myself and the confidence
that I had.
Our fictional world building
bleeds back into our realities.
>> JOHN MAEDA: We have two
minutes left.
Could you share a non-fiction
story you shared with me that
moved me very much about your
director, who I'm a huge fan of.
In Silicon Valley, we talk about
leadership, CEO, or the product
managers, the CEO of the
product, and the CEO-ish things.
I think of Ryan Kugler as one of
the creative CEO's of our time.
>> HANNAH BEACHLER: When I
was talking to myself? You
obviously know I'm weird.
We're working on "Creed," and
we're tech scouting.  You can
spend all day, and we had
stopped at this coffee shop, and
I got my coffee, and I was
working out a problem, and when
I'm trying to work out a problem
or solve a problem, I talk out
loud to myself, because that's
the best way to do it for me,
apparently.
And you know, my friends and
stuff, we
were like poke fun at me like
you're crazy, talking to
yourself.  So sometimes I do and
I don't know I'm doing it.  So
Ryan comes walking over to me,
and he was like, are you talking
to yourself? And I was like a
little like oh.  I know you and
love you, but yeah.
And the first thing he said when
he looked at me, he said that's
the sign of a really healthy
mind and a really intelligent
person.  And he turned around
and walked away.  And I was kind
of like ready to get
the hit of, like, oh, you're
crazy funny joke joke, but a
little bit of a slight.  And
that's not at all where his mind
came from.  It looked for the
immediate positive
thing about the thing that I was
doing.  Sometime that sometimes
people think is weird or could
make you feel a certain way
about yourself that eventually
starts beating you down and
making, you know, defining who
you are, because you're hearing
negative things about it.  That
is who Ryan is.  He's the person
that will constantly
lift people up, you know.
And he's not perfect, I promise.
There's days that I'm like
please make a decision.  You
have two hours.  And he does all
the things that directors do
that can completely bother you
or things that are like amazing.
He's the type of person like we
would
be on set for Warrior Falls
where they had the big fight.
And he gathered us all around in
a big circle.  Some people were
in the water.
And he really told us why that
scene was important.  This was
before we started shooting.  He
started to say why that scene
was important to him.
And really talked about having
all the
fictional tribes of Wakanda in
one place and represented by all
the references we
used, the different tribes in
sub Saharan Africa, and how that
was a big part of him really
feeling complete.  And you know,
you are holding hands
and he's telling us all this,
and we're standing in a circle,
and you feel like
you can take on the entire world
at that point.  So that's who he
is as a director and my friend.
And he is a really important
voice because his perspective on
anything and everything is the
most unique
perspective I promise you will
ever hear from anybody.  If you
ever get a chance to talk to
him, talk to him.  He will turn
a situation and make you
see it from a side you were
never maybe even meant to see it
from, and all the sudden your
world opens up.  And so I can
always -- he would be standing
here going like oh, please stop.
He is really that great.
>> JOHN MAEDA: Thanks for
sharing that story.  What a
leader, and what a designer.
Thank you.
>> HANNAH BEACHLER: Wow.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
S
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Brand ambassadors will assist
you in exiting through the
exits.